dans les tribunes rien ne lui échappe
alexandre taillefer est venu pour
observer les joueuses du grand prix du
conseil départemental des yvelines et
sportives venues des quatre coins de
l'île de france ont scruté avec
attention sur plusieurs critères pour
regarder les matches nous on a un fichu
fédéral qui nous permet de de dévaluer
sur est statistiquement les joueuses
avec des repères physiologiques des mots
des repères morphologique des repères
techniques des repères sur la
combativité et puis à partir de là on
on définit les postes ont mené des
joueurs vers le haut niveau c'est
l'objectif de ce tournoi créé il ya 32
ans
on est vraiment au premier niveau de la
détection en france cela je le jeune
joueur la serveuse donc ça rentre tout à
fait dans
dans l'objectif du comité c'est de dire
de voilà de détecter les jeunes et de
femmes et aux jeunes une source de
motivation pour les joueuses de 12 à 13
ans venus de huit départements
d'ile-de-france à se donner beaucoup
plus que ça en étant au club d'aller
vite fin faut donner le plus copé pour
augmenter renouveau aller au plus haut
niveau des cuisses et en 7 depuis une
dizaine d'années seulement 1 à 2 joueurs
par édition arrive à percer et à
intégrer les équipes de france ce jeune
[Applaudissements]